well Trump won the attention but whether
he won the debate by saying he wouldn't
support the Republican nominee is an
open question I think he hurt himself
except for a very small segment that he
has of the twenty-four percent he may
have peaked at twenty four percent but
last night's debate reminded me Neil of
I was at your Globe Theatre last night
actually also and I got two pens from
them when I saw Richard the third one
was witty fool or foolish wit and that
to me reminds Trump with his self
absorption yeah and the other is to be
or not to be which is the entire
republican party except for Jeb Bush on
the immigration issue yeah so those are
some things that came out but dealing
with Donald Trump ahead of ahead of last
night's to be everyone appeared to be
taking the strategy don't engage with
them you know he will blow up you know
he'll say something silly he didn't do
that and frankly although everyone knows
he's a bit policy light he wasn't
essentially directly challenge than that
either well he still bashed Mexicans in
last night's debate and he actually has
a point on Mexican jobs but I'll tell
you what if he had said it and I've told
my wife there's and she agrees to that
if he had said that eighty percent of
the women are raped when they come
across the border and who's doing the
raping it's the Mexican guys who are
coming with them that makes it
substantive and it narrows it to the
very people that we're talking about but
not all Mexicans are rapists you can't
win saying that and he had some other
things to say too I thought it was very
clever when he said that if Iran were a
stock by Iran because they're going to
quadruple in value with 150 billion in
sanctions relief only Trump's
perspective as a successful businessman
would be allow him to use that sound
bite what do we make of the performance
of the the next two of the of the big
three in all of this Jeb and Scott
Walker I mean both of them had an awful
lot to do last night and I'm by my
reckoning neither of them achieved it
Jeb is losing ground people are
recognizing that the energy isn't there
and that he really is just a cuddly face
in the mix of the American political
drama and by the way when he says I'm
not my dad I mean well we know that and
he respects his dad well that's great
except his dad brought us the Iraq war
and the economic crash so I don't think
Jeb is coming across very well
Walker is possibly either going to win
or vice presidential fodder but you have
to remember that he destroyed American
labor in Wisconsin and he killed the
unions and people are not going to
forget that one imagines that the next
time we get to a TV debate they'll be
even more this was only on network it
was it was it wasn't on network it was
it was carried on cable instead a plenty
more to discuss next time we're going to
have to leave it there i'm afraid book
but thanks very much for coming in and
look forward to the next time which are
very this my pleasure thank you so much